[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the video that you've all
been waiting for for so long I'd like to
introduce my special guest for today
mister jacksepticeye thank you thank you
everybody thank you thank you welcome to
my lens so we can't pull dance on our
own because we don't know how even if
i've done this before i still don't know
what i'm doing so to join us to teach us
to show us the way I'd like to welcome
Lolita
yeah Thank You Shawn have you ever done
this before
I have not not on record alright anyway
so we're basically beginners I've done
this twice and I still don't know what
I'm doing how long have you been doing
it about seven years seven years is that
how long it takes to be good oh no
everyone's a little bit different it
depends on the background what you bring
to it some people are have a gymnastics
background some people have a dance
background so it just depends I I both I
sit I sit at home a lot have you ever
taught somebody who's awful but got
really good um everyone starts at a
different place I wouldn't say awful but
maybe just not knowing and then of
course with time and practice they get
yeah but like the same day like as soon
as they touch the pole like they're
never know it rarely rarely they're like
oh well welcome to today you guys are
gonna prove me different right well
we're we're geniuses
I live for the pole we watch Rick and
Morty is there any like warm-ups that we
should do before we end
we're gonna be using our upper body
because last time it was majority leg
squeezing I got a cramp in my abs God
alright
I kind of call [ __ ] on this one oh
I'm not coordinated on my left thank you
am i dancing I feel real sexy
[Applause]
I said I said one move I could not say
combo I said first move go do it
okay I don't have tassels to flip I
don't have hair to flip first things
first you walked to the pole
yeah that that I saw I saw that then
everything after was a bit of a blur I
[Music]
feel powerful right now so you saunter
up yeah you grab dip slink get here all
right now set up you will see you did a
lot more well
okay okay after you Oh spend a week in
Thailand once did you like ice for me I
feel like I have to keep this hand like
this man okay what's next bolita
[Music]
war counts yeah okay all right so
saunter it's like learning like fight
choreography Shh shoulder wait okay this
okay we're get shifting I feel I feel
very mechanical do we shift our leg ease
when you we do this okay
our leg is everybody so fly I don't know
what to do with this hand okay so I
could just like Pat my stomach rub the
top of my head okay I think I got it oh
I'm feeling myself today lads well see I
wanted to shifty my leg ease but you
said no damn it see
rookie mistake not so good huh oh look
at though no so like this Oh God do I
look good no tell me I look good you
don't tell me I'm trash
I'm not going to okay nail it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I love that it's not called like the
swing around roundabout right mr. Bob
this is the sexy ass okay so sorry Lloyd
shoulder it and and but peddling out the
feet working this hand that was so you
walk on up you cup and you go around and
then you put your feet together pedal
out the feet bring the other hand up
that's the worst
yeah that's awful oh why would you do
that are you being able to do that and
not die
[Applause]
[Music]
all right here we go
here we go you see mark died on me there
he goes
there you go look at them peddling its
shoulder that's that's how we shorts
don't go very wide and I might be
revealing my balls to everybody this
Christ
are we good there any censorship
required that's not a sexy that was the
most painful thing ever my god oh just
wait till you do it I'm gonna feel
myself
oh okay and then we come back to poll
then we walk it out no oh no oh no I
hope my mom isn't watching this Oh a
sexy face I was hoping I would have more
freedom in these shorts but they're
awfully constricting right over I call
that one the spider-man Tom Holland call
me that Perry
she's doing it in these shoes and we
can't even do it what we're doing it
yeah oh sorry I didn't go into that sonn
ting at all area yeah walk it up
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow
thank you race full thank you oh no oh
yeah oh it's a good burn and then we
come down and then we do our Rd
monetization yeah let's do some tricks
okay
yes
flashy super tricks yeah let's go so
excited I was not talking about that no
no no I don't assault anyone excite on
the crucifix
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah don't you just talking normal
yeah this is just a Saturday oh I'm
going to be an MC wienie trip to the
hospital to start yeah I've got set what
is sane bolita that's good
what do you what do you want more skin
will this be okay we're going we're
going to do there we go okay so know
what not to do I've done something like
squeezed and had just legs up legs the
pole is in between my legs
yeah all right the slower you can give
them instruction once the speaker off
the ground the better good really really
give this a little Ripper Rooney yeah
really
I've been working my pit muscles for
this one Wow please why would you smell
that
why would you smell that okay so I'm
doing this oh my god this is nothing
okay so I'm just going oh God
don't die first try now I have to do it
twice
you know what's nuts that's my secret
yes squeeze intermediate-to-advanced
that was sexy yeah next please go
advanced I don't know why some do this
I'm a beginner we think I was just like
a bit hello yeah maybe more yeah I think
more more than higher more yeah run more
I try as we can maybe do it is more a
what just I've easy simple all right
there I have a problem all right
something here
yeah um oh it's better now okay problem
solved
[Music]
sure extended but I'll do this sexy
straddle that's me there you go mr. grip
they call me that they call me mr.
gorilla and then grab Oh No
where's the other hand go where's the
Sango between my legs I'm doing it okay
I believe it I did it well I did it
perfectly the first time why would I
need to do it again what are you talking
about next mores man please hard-ass
we both did that I don't know keep
organized in here just like you could do
a long time okay
this is a bit man thanks hard we could
die I know from that height if you look
at least we came time recently no no the
title or the - am a washed-up loser
nothing Oh depends on where it is yeah
why do you ask of course we all know
what my best grip squeezing the web
I'm so just a simple climb that feel
good was it worth it
yeah do you feel like a superhero now oh
yeah oh god how do you prick with your
elbow oh yeah oh yeah everywhere
yeah how do you do that oh practice
that's what we forgot oh how many
practice two three five practice
practice
I wasn't Superman I mean is it like a
square as a rectangle but a rectangle is
not a square kind of thing you know what
I mean yeah no it wasn't okay Oh
Superman okay okay and then right there
that's pretty wonderful yep grab
excellent it's bottom hand is going to
come down down yep good which like this
one okay I'm good
[Applause]
danger that seems much more doable yeah
I like that one we the ball out
squeezing okay it hurts in that place
she said
[Music]
Superboy I hid it for a second you did I
saw right
it's okay Superman's invincible anyway
so oh you're not hurt
uh-huh hold on I need skin there we go
it's good amount of skin showing Oh God
lower the pelvis she made it look so
easy yeah how's easy wait next next one
more let's finish it off strong some
flashy just you like a basically spinny
boy no no you do that on your channel on
mine we'd hurt okay everybody was paying
masochism it's good it is that's what I
always discovered when I first it I was
like this is an incredible workout you'd
get so so incredibly strong all right
wait did you mean for the guys to do I
thought were saying favor for the guys
to see yeah so carrying a little winter
weight I just went to Hawaii recently we
ate a lot of fruit hi I'm Lauren this is
an American
this is an inch is not what's exactly
holding me to the pole just sheer force
of will strength does that makes more
sense all right easy peasy
[Applause]
all right okay any second now on the
scale of one to ten how did we really do
that's not what we asked yeah yeah that
was pull dancing we did great look at
how strong we are
I feel so plush we feel so good and also
we've kind of special thing to say about
these shirts that we're wearing you may
notice that they say cloak it's because
Sean and I and a few other friends of
ours are launching a clothing brand yeah
that's not a joke that's not fakies at
all this is completely legit we just
want to let guests know about it
something that we've been working on for
a while now and people who are smarter
than us have been working on closely
because we wanted to make just we want
to make clothing that was stuff we
actually wanted to wear yeah exactly so
it's sometimes so hard to just be like
man it would be so easy if this stuff
wasn't what I had to deal with it was
something that I actually enjoyed
wearing every day so hi I just wanted to
interrupt and say that cloak brand comm
is live right now click on the link in
the description to go to cloak brand
comm or go directly to CLO a k BR AMD
dot-com and check out what we have for
pre-sale right now and I just wanted to
say thank you guys so much this launch
has been better than we ever could have
hoped for
I've been doing some Instagram live
streams over on cloak brand on Instagram
so I can answer some of you guys's
questions if you have any questions or
concerns please ask me during the
livestream tomorrow thank you guys so
much see you there
okay goodbye all right back to the pool
thank you so much for watching
look out for more details soon Thank You
Shawn for being here
Thank You Valletta for helping us if
will you come on down here
Thank You Bonita where can you find a
bolita online vivian liquors Vivian the
cruise on in baby liquors on V look
cruise on Instagram they'll be a link in
the description as well and if you want
more pole dancing don't worry there's
gonna be an entire another video over on
Shawn's check so check that out in the
description thank you guys so much and
as always see you in the next one bye
bye